Ja, war schon.
Okay. Haben Sie andere Beschwerden oder haben Sie andere Krankheiten?
Andere Krankheiten, sie meinen wie Bluthochdruck oder so?
Bluthochdruck oder so?
Nee, also bisher nicht.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente ein?
Nehmen Sie keine Medikamente, nur hin und wieder, wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen habe,
nehme ich vielleicht eine Paracetamol ein, aber sonst nehme ich keine regelmäßigen Medikamente ein.
Okay. Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Also Appetit hätte ich, ich könnte schon essen, aber ich kann nicht schluckern.
Sie können nichts schlucken.
Das ist nur mit festen Sachen, oder?
Nur feste Sachen, richtig.
Wenn Sie feste Sachen essen oder Essen probieren, probieren zu essen haben, was passiert genau?
Sie müssen übergehen oder?
Ja, das bleibt da oben hängen, also so über der Brust bleibt es hängen und nach einer gewissen Zeit kommt es wieder raus.
Haben Sie diese Beschwerden als erstes erfahrt oder im Vergangenheit haben Sie endlich Beschwerden?
Früher habe ich solche Beschwerden nicht gehabt, aber so vor ungefähr einem halben Jahr habe ich gemerkt,
wenn ich manchmal beim schlucken, dass mir das da weh getan habe, aber das ist jetzt mehr und mehr zugenommen
und jetzt geht das nicht mehr runter.
Haben Sie Husten?
Nur Husten habe ich nicht.
Wenn Sie etwas schlucken, gibt es ein Blut oder andere Winge?
Nein, Blut habe ich bisher nicht dabei gehabt.
In letzter Zeit haben Sie so etwas abgenommen?
Ich meine, ein Gewicht verloren?
Ja, ich glaube so um die 20 kg.
Wie viel Zeit? 1, 2 Monate oder 1 Jahr?
In welcher Zeit?
Ja, so ungefähr in 3 Monaten.
Haben Sie für diese Beschwerden zum Asken gegangen?
Hallo?
Hallo, können Sie mich hören?
Ja, jetzt hör ich Sie. Irgendwie war das eingefroren.
Ihre Internetverbindung ist instabil, meine oder Ihre?
Ich bin nicht sicher.
Ich kann Sie nicht gut hören?
Sie können mich nicht hören.
Wenn der Mann hat eine Internetverbindung, sind Sie für diese Beschwerden zum Asken gegangen?
Nein, bisher bin ich nicht zum Asken gegangen. Das ist das erste Mal.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Verdauentrack?
Nein, bisher nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Nein, Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen habe ich keine Probleme.
Was ist die Farbe von Ihrer Stuhlgang?
Also ganz normal, bräunlich.
Es gibt kein Blut oder andere Dinge.
Blut habe ich im Stuhl nicht gesehen.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Ihrer Lungen?
Wie meint ihr, ob ich Luftnot habe?
Nichts Not oder dass Sie können gut atmen?
Mit Atmen habe ich keine Probleme, mit der Luft eigentlich auch nicht.
Ich mache regelmäßig Sport, ich laufe auch ein bisschen.
Da habe ich keine Probleme mit.
Haben Sie schon bemerkt, gibt es Luftnoten in Ihren Hals oder anderen Körperteilen?
Haben Sie das gemerkt?
Sie meinen eine Schwellung?
Nein, eine Schwellung habe ich nirgendwo getastet.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Schützen Sie in der Nacht so viel?
Letzte Zeit ja, ich kenne das eigentlich nicht.
Aber in den letzten Wochen merke ich, dass meine Kleidung nass wird,
auch dass das Bett ein bisschen nass wird.
Haben Sie Ihre Kleidung gewechselt?
In den letzten Wochen bin ich ein paar Mal aufgestanden nass und habe sie gewechselt.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Schlafen?
Schlafstührung habe ich nicht.
Lauchen Sie?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Ich habe keine Probleme mit.
Ich rauche nicht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, ich habe keine Probleme mit.
Ich habe keine Probleme mit.
Probiere Sie Drogen?
Nein, ich habe keine Probleme mit.
Haben Sie etwas Allergie?
Unverträglichkeiten, ich bin mir jetzt auch nicht bewusst.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, eine Tochter und einen Sohn.
Sind Sie gesund?
Sie sind beide gesund.
Sie leben noch nicht, oder?
Können Sie ihn hören?
Ja, ich höre Sie. Meine Eltern leben nicht mehr.
Hatten Sie eine Krankheit?
Oder eine Beschwerde?
Nein, mein Vater ist an einem Schlaganfall gestorben.
Meine Mutter ist ganz normal.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin mittlerweile berichtet.
Ich war früher Industriem Mechaniker.
Herr Müller, habe ich alle wichtige Fragen von mir gefragt.
Wenn Sie etwas hinzubekommen möchten, können Sie mir sagen.
Wenn Sie mich so fragen, dann können Sie mich sagen.
Ich habe schon viele Jahre immer mit Aufstoßenproblemen gehabt.
Können Sie bitte hören?
Ich habe viele Jahre aufstoßen gehabt.
Im Schlaf, dass mir der Mageninhalt in die Speiseröhre hochgewandert ist.
Wie viele Jahre?
Ich habe schon viele Jahre mit Aufstoßenproblemen gehabt.
Das sind vielleicht 10, 15 Jahre schon gewesen.
Sind Sie für diese Beschwerden zum Ausgehen gegangen?
Nein, ich bin nicht.
Ich wusste aber, ich darf abends nicht essen.
Vor allem spät nicht essen, nichts trinken.
Das Problem war nicht da.
Ich habe Feiern, wenn ich mal abends etwas gegessen habe.
Dann habe ich gemerkt, ich darf nicht flach liegen.
Die ganze Soße kommt mir in den Mund.
Sie sagen, wenn Sie trinken, gibt es das Problem.
Was trinken Sie?
Nein, wenn ich etwas getrunken habe.
Das kann auch Wasser sein oder Tee sein.
Nichts Besonderes.
Dann nehmen Sie bestimmte Medikamente für die Aufstoßenprobleme ein.
Keine Medikamente.
Herr Müller, jetzt muss ich für alle Untersuchungen durchführen.
Manche andere Untersuchungen können auch mit Abnehmen machen.
Und mein Oberarzt sprechen.
Dann kann ich mit Ihnen Ihre Beschwerden oder bestimmte Diagnose sagen.
Bitte warten Sie in dem Wartraum.
Dann können wir noch einmal sprechen.
Gut.
Sie haben sicherheit, dass Sie Nervestat, Unruhe, Müdigkeit,
Konzentration, Schwere, Leistung verlüßt.
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Sie haben Herzrasen, Stolpen,
bei Belastung auf der Erdbeutung.
Sie haben die Erdbeutung, die Sie haben,
Ich habe es nicht bemerkt.
Wie viel können Sie steigen, bevor Sie auf der Tatum bleiben?
Das kann ganz normal.
3 Stockwerke können schon steigen.
Haben Sie verschlucken?
Ich bin nicht verschlucken.
Ich kann nur nicht richtig schlucken.
Aber verschlucken?
Nein.
Herr Oberarzt.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ich möchte eine Patient vorstellen.
Herr Müller, 75 Jahre alt.
67 kg und 1,75 m groß.
Er habe seit 4-5 Wochen ein schulkem Problem.
Es gibt ein bisschen Schmerzen,
nur beim Schulkem.
Die Schulkem-Programme gibt es nicht nur mit festen Sachen,
aber mit Politikern gibt es kein Problem.
Er hat eine Schmerz-Serie,
aber er hat auch ein Schulkem-Programm.
Er hat keine Medikamente.
Er hat nur für Kopfschmerzen,
aber auch für Parasitöre benutzt.
Und der Schulkem-Programm hat ein Abstoßenproblem.
Er hat ein Abstoßenproblem seit sehr langer Zeit.
Er hat keine Medikamente.
Er benutzt keine Medikamente?
Er hat kein Arzt für Medikamente besucht?
Er hat keine Medikamente.
Medikamente werden nicht benutzt.
Man nimmt sie ein.
Man sagt nicht, er benutzt keine Medikamente,
aber er nimmt keine Medikamente ein.
Er nimmt keine Medikamente ein.
Er hat kein Problem mit Abitit,
oder Schlafen, oder andere Dinge.
Er hat in den letzten 3 Monaten
20 kg abgenommen.
Er hat keine Medikamente.
Er hat auch in der letzten Woche
so viel Nachschweiß.
Er musste ein paar Mal die Kleidung wechseln.
Er ist kein Raucher.
Er hat kein Alkohol, kein Trocken.
Er hat keine Energien oder auch keine Medikamente.
Er ist verhörwärtet.
Seine Kinder sind gesund.
Er wird nicht leben.
Er ist gestorben.
Er hat einen Schlaganfall.
Mutter hat einen normalen Grund.
Er ist Rentner.
Die Mutter ist natürlich gestorben.
Er ist natürlich gestorben.
Er ist Rentner,
aber er war in der Industriemechanik.
Er hat kein Problem mit Herz- oder Lungen.
Er ist Rentner, aber er war in der Industriemechanik.
Er ist in der Industriemechanik.
Nach der langen Anonyse
ist meine Produktdiagnose
BE Seemskal souffrie GüschHHH.
Als differenzial diagnostisch, differenzial diagnostisch würde ich sagen es kann ja Akalasia sein.
Ja, eine Akalasia.
Oder eine Verrückung von Magentaschen.
Ich werde große Blut mitmachen und Ultraschall und CT machen.
Was sollten Sie dann vor dem CT oder Ultraschall sofort in die Wege leiden?
Ja, vielleicht kann ich eine so farbe Diagnoskopie machen.
Ja, die Magenspiegelung. Einmal schauen, was ist da los, warum kann dieser Mensch nicht schlucken.
Und man wird schon sehen, je nachdem wo die Schluckstörung ist, ob das im Sufferguss ist,
in der Speiseröhre, also im Übergangsbereich, oder ob das irgendwie der Mageneingangsbereich ist.
Oder ob da überhaupt keine Verengung da ist, das vielleicht dem CT von außen draufdrückt.
Kann ja auch sein, zum Beispiel in ein Tumor, der im Mediathin umwächst und die Speiseröhre einfach zusammendrückt.
Und Sie haben jetzt die Magenspiegelung gemacht und der Gastroenterologe sagt, er sieht so im distalen Sufferguss, also im unteren Bereich,
sieht der einen Tumor, der zirkulär die gesamte Zirkumferenz, also drumherum wächst und nicht passierbar.
Und der hat daraus Proben entnommen.
Gut. Und er sagt, das sieht verdächtig aus wie ein Suffergusskart.
Und jetzt machen wir als nächster Schritt, das gehört an Paging, ja, als nächster Schritt.
Was machen Sie dann?
Als nächster Schritt, müssten wir Therapie planen?
Nun noch nicht, noch nicht. Erst mal müssen wir natürlich die Untersuchungen komplettieren.
Wir wollen wissen, ist das jetzt ein Tumor, der nur auf die Speiseröhre, auf den Sufferguss begrenzt ist?
Oder hat der irgendwo hingestreut?
Wir müssen erst mal ein Stadium festlegen, was für ein Stadium haben wir denn überhaupt?
Wo überall befindet sich die Erkrankung?
Und erst danach kann ich dann die Therapie planen.
Man muss also erst mal was machen.
Müssen wir jetzt zuerst kontrollieren, ob ein Metastas gibt oder nicht, auszusammeln,
müssen wir ein Pet-CT machen.
Ja, Pet-CT nicht sofort.
In Deutschland wird Pet-CT nicht immer bezahlt.
Und Pet-CT macht man hier sehr selten.
Man begnügt sich mit dem normalen CT, ne?
Eine Computertomographie von Brust und von Bauch, also Thorax-Abdomen.
Und dann guckt man sich an, gibt es lokale oder etwas weitere Lymphknoten?
Gibt es Lungenmetastasen?
Gibt es Lebermetastasen?
Oder gibt es vielleicht im oberen Bauchbereich, also im Sinterium,
irgendwelche Lymphknotenmetastas?
Und sie haben die CTs gemacht.
Und es sieht nur lokal so kleine oder etwas vermehrte Lymphknoten,
die nicht vergrößert sind.
Sonst sieht ja keine Metastas.
Gut.
Es gibt kein Metastas, nur lokale Tumor.
Und in diesem Fall müssen wir die Staging aufdrücken.
Auf Deutsch, ich kann nicht sagen, ich bin nicht so Staging machen.
Es gibt im Deutschen keinen Begriff dafür.
Auf Deutsch, ich bin nicht sehr.
Es gibt kein Staging. Es gibt kein Deutsches Wort für Staging.
Man sagt auch im Deutsch Staging durch.
Wir müssen Staging machen und können wir auch mit Onkologie ein Konzil planen.
Vielleicht eine Chirurgie.
Ich glaube, in diesem Fall können wir keine Operation machen.
Vielleicht müssen wir nur Radio- und Chemotherapie planen.
Und vielleicht gibt es auch andere Probleme mit Konflikationen.
Das können wir ein Reha planen.
Nur langsam, nur langsam.
Wir müssen jetzt Schritt für Schritt vorgehen.
Sie haben die Computertumografie gemacht.
Man sieht keine Fernmetastasen.
Und der Radiologe sagt, vielleicht so lokale Lymphknoten.
Was gehört aber noch mit dazu bei distalen Suffacus-Karsinomen
oder aber einem AEG?
Wissen Sie, was ein AEG ist?
Ich weiß nicht.
Haben Sie noch nicht gehört.
Das nennt sich ein Adenokarsinom des esophagogastralen Überganges.
AEG.
Das ist ein englischer Begriff.
Deshalb E, esophageal, esophagogastral.
Adenokarsinom esophagogastral, also AEG.
Das wird je nach Lokalisation als 1, 2 oder 3 bezeichnet.
Sprich, wenn der größte Anteil des Tumors eher in esophagos ist,
ist das ein AEG 1.
Mittlerweile wird das aber als distales Adenokarsinom des esophagos bezeichnet.
Oder aber der Übergangsbereich von der Speiseröhre zum Magen,
dann ist es ein AEG 2.
Wenn der größte Teil des Tumors im Magen liegt, dann ist es ein AEG 3.
Aber die liegen alle sehr dicht beieinander
und können alle solche Schluckstörungen eigentlich machen.
Das darf man nicht vergessen.
Und daneben gibt es auch die reinen Plattenepithel-Karsinomen,
esophagos-Karsinoma.
Das kann natürlich, der Pathologe muss jetzt gucken, was es ist.
Ist das ein Plattenepithel-Esofagos-Karsinom
oder ist es ein Adenokarsinom?
Die werden nämlich unterschiedlich behandelt.
Sie haben gesagt, sie würden den Chirurgen direkt fragen,
mittlerweile sagt man bei einem Adenokarsinom, also AEG,
macht man überwiegend eine neoadjuvante Chemotherapie.
Aber bevor man eine neoadjuvante Chemotherapie macht,
dann sollte eine diagnostische Lapparoscopie erfolgen.
Warum?
Weil diese Adenokarsinome sehr leicht eine Peritonealkarsinose hervorrufen.
Liegt eine Peritonealkarsinose vor, dann operiert man den nicht.
Das ist dann ein Stadium 4, der ist entfernt metastasiert
und dann operiert man diese Leute nicht.
Wenn keine Peritonealkarsinose vorliegt,
dann macht man erst mal eine neoadjuvante Chemotherapie.
Die Daten haben gezeigt, dass das Outcome, die Überlebensraten,
bei Patienten, die neoadjuvant behandelt wurden, viel besser ist.
Deshalb gibt es die Empfehlung, Adenokarsinome sollten neoadjuvant vorbehandelt werden.
Bei esophaguskarzinomen, Plattenepithel als Histologie, ist das ein bisschen anders.
Da kann man natürlich im distalen esophagus direkt operieren.
Man kann aber auch zunächst neoadjuvante Radiochemotherapie, das ist schon richtig.
Aber nur bei Plattenepithelkarzinomen.
Danach kann man das dann resistieren lassen.
Aber bei esophaguskarzinomen gibt es entweder die alleinige Chemotherapie, neoadjuvant.
Man kann aber auch kombiniert Radiochemotherapie, neoadjuvant.
Und dann sagen, wenn es vertretbar ist, auch operieren.
Beides ist nicht so schön.
Das wird meistens in so speziellen Zentren gemacht.
Nicht jeder Chirurg beherrscht die Technik der esophagusresekzion.
Da gibt es viele verschiedene Formen.
Ich sehe der Dr. Aligie, der kennt sich damit besser aus.
Er ist Chirurg.
Aber man kann einen Magen-Ruchzug machen.
Man kann einen Colon-Interponat machen.
Das ist ein zwei-Höhleneingriff, sagt man.
Das muss aber der Chirurg selber entscheiden, je nachdem, wie die Lage des Karzinomens ist.
Wie viel vom esophagus resistiert werden muss.
All das muss natürlich miteinander besprochen werden.
Dafür gibt es in Deutschland fast überall, muss man sagen, ein Tumorboard.
Wo dann die Fälle, die Patienten interdisziplinär, sagt man, mit Chirurg,
mit Strahlentherapie, mit Gastroenterologe und Onkologe und Radiologe,
Pathologe, gemeinsam durchspricht.
Man weiß, welches Prozedere das Beste für den Patienten ist.
Das Gleiche gilt aber auch für einen Magen-Karzinom.
Auch Magen-Karzinome im limitierten Stadion,
ohne Peritonellkarzinose.
Wenn die in einem fortgeschrittenen Stadion sind,
mindestens ein Stadium 3,
dann werden die automatisch neoadjuans behandelt.
Deshalb wollte ich vorhin noch sagen,
zum Staging gehört neben der Computertomographie
auch eine Endosonographie.
Ein endosophagealer Ultraschall.
Dass man dann einmal guckt, ist es im Ultraschall auch sichtbar,
dass dafür größerte Lymphknoten da sind.
Wenn ja, dann ist auf jeden Fall die neoadjuvantische Chemotherapie
indiziert.
Wenn kein Lymphknoten da ist,
und das ist ein limitiertes Stadion,
Stadium 2 zum Beispiel, oder Stadium 1,
dann werden diese Leute primär operiert.
Aber mit Lymphknotenbefall oder aber ein Stadium 3,
also T3,
dann werden sie erstmal neoadjuvantchemotherapiert.
Und dieser Mensch, der hat ein Adenokarzinom.
Und in diesem Falle passt es zu einem AEG1.
Oder nach neuer Nomen, Klatur,
ist es ein Adenokarzinom des distalen Oesophagus.
Und der würde jetzt erstmal eine neoadjuvantische Chemotherapie
bekommen.
Welche Substanzen, das müsst ihr nicht wissen,
das muss aber der Hermator Onkologe wissen.
Der ist 75 Jahre alt,
aber der ist noch in einem sehr guten allgemeinen Zustand.
Der hat keine Komorbiditäten.
Man müsste sicherlich das Herz noch mal untersuchen,
die Lunge noch mal untersuchen.
Wenn all das in Ordnung ist,
dann kann man dem sicherlich die empfohlene Flotttherapie geben.
Das ist eine Kombination aus Oxaliplatin,
Doctetaxil und 5FU mit Follinat.
Aber das kann auch schwierig werden bei einem 75-Jährigen.
Er ist in einem guten Zustand.
Ich würde es riskieren.
Man gibt es insgesamt viermal.
Und dann guckt man, ob der Tumor kleiner geworden ist oder nicht.
Und dann operiert sich die Rokmeister.
Und wo strahlen tut man dann in diesem Falle eher nicht.
Alternativ kann man auch sagen, wenn er nicht operabel ist,
warum auch immer, wenn er Herz krank ist,
oder aber Lungen krank ist,
man spricht dann funktionell inoperabelem Zustand,
dann kann man den Alternativ auch kombiniert Radiochemotherapien
und operiert ihn dann nicht mehr.
Das wäre die andere Alternative.
Was man manchmal auch machen kann, ist, dass man sagt,
man macht zwar eine Neohydrobande Chemotherapie,
aber der Patient soll auch selber was essen.
Manche legen da einen Stent.
So ein Fabus Stent kann man auch da reinlegen.
Das ist auch eine Möglichkeit.
Ich mag es nicht so gerne,
weil der Stent manchmal doch Probleme macht.
Der kann distoziieren, der kann auch mal perforieren,
der kann auch mal Blutungen verursachen.
Und dann hat man noch mehr Probleme,
vielleicht die Therapie unterbrechen und so weiter.
Und ich habe häufig die Beobachtung gemacht,
unter der Therapie wird die Schluckstörung besser.
Wenn die Chemo wirkt,
dann können die Patienten meistens wieder gut essen.
Und natürlich haben Sie sehr gut gefragt,
solche Tumore können auch sehr leicht bluten.
Es kann auch zu einer Anämie gekommen sein.
Er hat es aber nicht gehabt.
Und dann hätte er natürlich auch einen Leistungsknick,
schwäche Konzentrationsstörung, Luftnot und so weiter und so weiter.
Das hat er alles aber nicht gehabt,
weil er anscheinend aus dem Tumor nicht geblutet hat.
Okay.
Okay, danke.
Danke sehr.
Für diese Patienten,
welche Prognose werden Sie?
Also die Prognose für diesen Patienten
ist eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht nach heutiger,
heutigem Standard.
Wenn er die Therapie durchsteht
und er ist gut zu operieren,
dann hat er eigentlich eine sehr gute Chance, geheilt zu sein.
Ich würde sagen, so über 50 Prozent.
Das ist vor 20 Jahren so nicht der Fall gewesen.
Mit den modernen Medikamenten
und mit den modernen Vorgehensweisen, Staging, Geräten und so weiter
kann man die Prognose des Patienten deutlich verbessern.
Und vor Jahren gab es eben diese Flottsstudie
und da hat man teilweise auch
unter der neo-adiwanden Chemotherapie
auch komplette pathologische Remissionen gesehen.
Sprich, der Tumor war komplett abgestorben.
Man hatte zwar irgendwie Restareal,
aber da waren keine vitalen Zellen enthalten,
so dass das eine Revolution war.
Man hat sozusagen mit der Chemotherapie den Patienten geheilt,
operiert, während er aber trotzdem,
weil da noch ein gewisses Restrisiko drinsteckt,
dass daraus immer noch ein Tumor entstehen kann,
dass der Erkrankung wiederkommen kann.
Spreche ich zu viel oder zu fachmännisch?
Versteht mich jeder?
Oder bleibt manches unverstanden?
Ich verstehe das alles.
Ja, Sie sind sehr nett.
Ich möchte Ihnen diese Informationen
jeden unterrichten.
Sehr gut, ich denke.
Okay, herrlich klar.